[Music]  my other girl from bridgeton to anita  um the whole crew was fired  you guys rose up in this we rolled deep  in the mosquito party bus what was going  on it's like oh see everybody was up top  oh wait what'd you say how was it  outfitted inside you know everybody was  partying up top you don't have to get at  the bottom where the air conditioning  was  but it was so fun it was so fun  why did you have to invite this lovely  one back from mormon and it's hot girl  matt meg tonight it's the mad gala  oh yeah cause you know i'm always  killing it with the nails oh my goodness  you had a moment in houston recently  congratulations to the city and i got my  own day in honor of my mom and my  grandma